YouTube
We live in a world of overused hyperbole.
Still it is hard to overstate the phenomenon
that is YouTube.
In just over a decade, it has risen from nothing
to 7 billion hours of video watched every
month.
It is the third most visited site on the internet,
with 80 percent of viewers coming from outside
the United States.
It has more than 1.5 billion monthly users,
who are entertained by 400 hours worth of
video uploaded every 60 seconds.
And it has made a lot of people a whole lot
of money…
But have you ever stopped and wondered how
YouTube came about?
It’s a fascinating story and today, you
are going to discover it all as Biographics
goes behind the screen to bring you the real
YouTube story.
The Idea
It all started with a chance encounter in
1999.
Eric Skaggs, a local entrepreneur, was finishing
up some work on his website at the Eberly
College of Business computer lab at Indiana
University of Pennsylvania.
His website was called GoGetItNow.com, and
was an amalgamation of email, search engine
and web hosting combined into a single interface.
As he was about to leave the building, Skaggs
saw a rather tall guy in a baseball camp entering.
They struck up a conversation and Skaggs learnt
that this guy, Chad Hurley, was a graphics
arts major who was looking for an idea for
a website.
The idea that Skaggs gave to Hurley was to
provide the inspiration for the YouTube revolution...
He told him that in the future television
and computers would become fully integrated.
Furthermore people would be able to use their
cell phones to create home videos and they
would want a platform to share them with friends
and family.
Remember, this was at a time when there were
no cameras with video in phones and TV and
the internet were very different animals.
The idea was a little overwhelming for Hurley
and he stored it away for future reference.
After graduating from Indiana University with
a fine arts degree he started looking for
employment in the exciting new internet industry.
He picked up a copy of Wired magazine which
had an article featuring the Top 10 website
companies from his local grocery store.
Hurley sat down and redesigned those companies
logos, sending them to the marketing departments.
The one he did for a company called Paypal
caught the eye of co-founder Eion Musk and,
before he knew it, Hurley was hired as the
company’s first graphic designer.
PayPal
It was at PayPal that Hurley was able to pick
the brains of the most brilliant techie nerds
in the industry.
The two smartest guys in the room were Steve
Chen and Jawed Karim.
Chen was born in Taiwan in 1978, with his
family moving to the United States when he
was eight years old.
He attended the Illinois Mathematics and Science
Academy where he proved to be a maths prodigy.
His passion was computer engineering, and
he went on to study computer science at the
University of Illinois.
He began working for Paypal in 1999, a few
months before Hurley.
Jawed Karim was born in Merseburg, Germany
in 1979, moving with his family to the U.S.
when he was thirteen.
From the start, Jawed was a computer wiz.
In school he wrote computer programs, posting
them on the internet for free.
He also helped to set up the schools’ e-mail
system.
Just like Steve Chen, Karim went to the University
of Illinois, where he studied computer science.
After a number of internships with a range
of technology companies, he sought employment
with Paypal in 2000, where he was put to work
on designing the company’s anti-fraud security
system.
Hurley, the graphic designer, Chen, the engineer
and Karim, the systems guru, soon found each
other and spent more and more time brainstorming
ideas for their own start-up.
For five years, they kicked around ideas while
building up their knowledge and experience
at Paypal.
Then, in January of 2005, Hurley was hosting
a dinner party at his home.
Chen was in attendance and he began using
a camcorder to take some video of the festivities.
The next day they wanted to share the video
with those who had been in attendance.
The problem was that the video files were
way too big to send by email.
And, even though there were a few photo sharing
websites, such as Flickr and Shutterfly, nothing
existed for the sharing of video online.
It was at this point that the seed that had
been planted years before came to life.
Teaming with Karim, they decided to create
a website to share videos.
The idea was to use the video sharing platform
to create a dating site.
People would post self videos for potential
partners to view and respond to if they liked
what they saw.
They called it ‘Tune In, Hook Up.’
They launched the site within days and then
waited for the users to come.
However, nothing happened.
In an attempt to get some content up on the
site, they placed ads on Craigslist, offering
to pay people to post videos.
Still, no one was interested and ‘Tune In,
Hook Up’ became a huge flop.
The trio were disheartened but not dismayed.
Shortly after the demise of their first joint
venture, Jawed was frustratingly searching
online for a video of Janet Jackson’s infamous
2004 Superbowl half-time show wardrobe malfunction.
Because there was no user friendly platform
for sharing video content, he was unable to
satisfy his breast fetish.
Together with Hurley and Chen, he decided
to do something about it.
Stripping away the lame dating concept, they
were left with a video uploading and sharing
platform.
All they need now was a new name for their
website.
Founding
On February 14th, 2005, in a humble apartment
above a California pizza shop, the trio began
building their new website.
Initially, apparently in reference to Janet
Jackson’s unwitting contribution, they wanted
to call it BoobTube.
Realizing that that sounded too much like
a porn site, they began playing around with
words that conveyed the idea of personalized
television.
Harking back to the days when the TV was called
‘the tube’ thanks to the cathode ray tube
that powered it, one of the three (no one
knows which one) came up with YouTube.
It sounded perfect - it was short, catchy
and fun and it perfectly summed up what they
were about.
When Hurly applied to register the domain
name, the idea was to go with Utube with a
‘U’.
However that domain name was already taken,
which forced him to precede ‘Tube’ with
the three letter word “You.’
Hurly, Chen and Karim immediately set about
writing down the goals for YouTube.
At the top of the list was ease of user experience.
Loading and watching videos had to be super
easy, so that even the most computer illiterate
person could do it.
They then divided up the workload.
Chad Hurly was in charge of the look and design
of the site as well tagging and labelling
loaded videos to make them easy for viewers
to find.
Steve Chen was the engineer who made sure
that the site was running smoothly and that
videos played without lagging.
Jawid Karim, meanwhile, used his programming
skills to get the site up and running and
looking great.
Unlike the other two, Karim chose not to be
an employee of the company.
Instead his role was that of an informal advisor.
This allowed him to focus on his graduate
studies in computer science at Stanford University.
The first video ever loaded onto YouTube was
an eighteen second long clip of Karim at the
San Diego zoo entitled ‘Me at the Zoo.’
You can still watch this historic clip on
the site, where it has been seen by more than
30 million people.
Hurly was put in charge of marketing.
He started a competition where a different
YouTube user was given an Apple Ipod Nano
every day for 8 weeks.
People earned points by referring a friend
or posting a video.
The more points you gained, the greater your
chances of winning the Ipod.
The promotion worked and people began flooding
the site with video content.
However, this created a problem.
So much content was coming onboard that YouTube
was running out of bandwidth.
This made video playback excruciatingly slow.
They were desperately in need of more storage
capacity, which required money.
But, as of yet, they weren’t making any.
Fortunately, on the basis of future ad revenue
forecasts, they were able to secure a $3.5
million dollar venture capital loan in November,
2005.
Just a month earlier a Nike promotional video
featuring Brazilian football star, Ronaldhino,
became the first Youtube clip to reach one
million views.
Explosive Growth
By the beginning of 2006, YouTube had grown
to more than 60 employees and the site had
more than 100 million videos.
This was an astounding level of growth, considering
that just 12 months earlier they literally
couldn’t pay people to post videos on their
website.
Over the course of its first year the nature
of the content being loaded on YouTube evolved.
During the first few months the majority of
clips were of the home movie variety.
But then more and more ‘How To’ videos
began appearing, with advice being offered
on everything from how to change the oil in
your car to the proper technique for doing
a barbell squat.
As a result, YouTube was fast becoming the
go to source for both entertainment and information.
In June, 2006 YouTube entered into a contract
with NBC television.
This marked a u-turn by NBC, who had previously
forced YouTube to remove a Saturday Night
live clip after it became a viral hit online.
Now NBC agreed to pay YouTube to place promotional
clips of their shows, behind the scenes interviews
and other features on the website.
Google Buyout
YouTube was by now attracting the attention
of the biggest players in the Web universe.
The site was wildly popular with viral videos
regularly appearing on TV news broadcasts,
and even entire shows being devoted to YouTube
content.
The sort of global reach that YouTube had
acquired was extremely inviting to the biggest
player of them all.
In October, 2006, the Google corporation purchased
YouTube for a staggering 1.65 billion dollars.
The three tech nerds from Paypal now had more
money than they could possibly spend in a
lifetime.
Despite being independently wealthy beyond
measure, Hurley and Chen stayed with YouTube.
In fact, they were thrilled to be working
with such a Web giant as Google.
They now had the freedom to focus on adding
new technology to the website.
In an effort to encourage people to stay on
the site for longer, they added extra features,
including suggestions of follow up videos
the viewer may be interested in watching.
They also set to work on making the YouTube
experience available through a greater range
of devices.
YouTube’s mobile app let people watch videos
on their cell phones and people could now
add YouTube clips to their websites and blogs.
In a move that emphasized just how dominant
YouTube was in people’s lives, Time magazine
featured a YouTube Screen on the cover of
its 2006 Person of the year issue.
Paying Creators
In May, 2007, the YouTube Partner Program
was launched.
This allowed people who uploaded videos to
have a share in the ad revenue generated by
advertising that was played during the video.
Now, for the first time, every day people
were able to turn their hobbies into successful
online businesses.
The program, which is still in operation,
pays uploaders around 55% of the ad revenue.
Over the last decade this revenue source has
paid off big time for a relatively small number
of creators, known as YouTubers, who have
created massive followings and huge annual
earnings.
They have also been able to leverage their
popularity to obtain sponsorship deals with
merchandisers who are keen to get their products
in the videos.
Some of these YouTubers have even landed movie
and TV roles as a result of their online fame.
Impact
2007 was also the year that YouTube began
impacting politics.
Seven of the thirteen candidates for the Presidency
of the United States announced their campaigns
through YouTube.
This was followed by the first YouTube presidential
debate which featured questions submitted
by viewers.
In 2009, the capability was introduced to
upload and watch 3-D videos on YouTube.
That same year the staggering milestone of
one billion views per day was reached.
Less than three years later that number had
mushroomed to 4 billion.
The first video to reach one billion views
was the unforgettable ‘Gangnam Style’
by PSY which reached the milestone on December
21, 2012.
In 2011, the new feature of livestreaming
was added.
Now major world events could be watched in
real time, making YouTube a viable alternative
to the television set.
But YouTube was soon to prove that it was
more than just a recorder of historical events.
January 25th, 2011 was a day of protest against
the government of President Hosni Mubarak
in Cairo, Egypt.
Throughout that day video of the proclaimed
‘day of rage’ began appearing on YouTube.
This inspired and emboldened thousands of
Egyptian citizens who came pouring out into
the streets.
The protests went on for 18 days and the protesters
were able to use YouTube, along with Facebook
and Twitter, to galvanize the support that
would eventually lead to change.
Mubarak’s regime reacted to the skilful
use of the internet on the part of its detractors
by imposing a sweeping crackdown of the internet.
This only further enraged the protesters,
eventually forcing Mubarak to step down and
democratic elections to be held for the first
time in decades.
2011 also saw a major overhaul of the website’s
look.
The video channels were displayed in a central
column and the YouTube logo was updated.
The Google Chrome web browser was also integrated
so that viewers could watch YouTube directly
watched through Google+.
Two years later, YouTube began offering paid
subscriptions.
For a monthly fee, this service allowed subscribers
to watch longer, ad free videos and movies.
Where are They Now?
So, what are the founders of YouTube up to
now?
In October of 2010, Chad Hurley stepped down
as CEO of YouTube, handing the reins over
to Salar Kamangar.
He committed to staying on as an advisor to
the company.
Steve Chen left the company at about the same
time and the two began collaborating on a
new venture, AVOS Systems.
Their headline product was an iPhone app called
MixBit, which allows users to shoot, edit
and share video clips.
AVOS systems has acquired a number of other
companies, including Delicious and Tap 11.
Chad Hurley was also a major sponsor of the
USF1 Formula One racing team.
He is also a part owner of NBA team the Golden
State Warriors and the MLS Los Angeles Football
Club.
In 2014, after fifteen of years of collaboration,
Chen and Hurley parted company.
Chad took over full control of MixBit, while
Chen went over to Google Ventures as an entrepreneur
in residence.
Making it clear that there was no animosity
in the parting, Chen explained . . .
Actually, it was a very personal and difficult
decision to make, but with the decision to
turn Avos into MixBit it became pretty clear.
MixBit was Chad’s idea before we started
Avos and even at YouTube, and if I feel driven
to work on other projects, then I’m just
getting in the way of mixbit and the team.
Jawed Karim completed his graduate studies
at the University of Illinois, emerging with
a Master’s degree in Computer Science.
Of the three founders, he received the lowest
portion of stock.
However, this was still enough for him to
earn around $64 million from the sale to Google.
In 2008, he launched Youniversity Ventures,
which provides mentorship, expertise and contacts
for college students to take innovative products
to the next level.
Karim was also one of the first investors
in Airbnb in 2009.
Towards the end of 2013, Karim hit the headlines
when he objected, along with many other YouTube
users, to Google’s requirement that commenting
on YouTube videos only be done through a Google
+ account.
He showed his displeasure by changing the
description on his iconic ‘Me at the zoo’
video to read . . .
I can’t comment here anymore since I don’t
want a google+ account.
As a result of Karim’s stance, backed up
by a 240,000 signature petition, Google dropped
its requirement that commenters must use their
Google + product.
The Future
It is truly mind-blowing to contemplate just
how big YouTube will become in the next few
years.
New features are constantly being rolled out
to enhance the viewer experience.
YouTube has already replaced TV as the main
source of entertainment and information for
many people.
According to Google Executive chairman Eric
Schmidt, the exponential growth of YouTube
will bring it six or seven billion unique
visitors per month, with that growth being
largely driven from the developing world.
YouTube has became a launching pad for a growing
number of breakout stars, including Justin
Bieber and Greyson Chance.
There have also been a number of TV shows
that began life as skits on YouTube, including
Broad City and Workaholics.
YouTube is the most public place in the world,
accessible from the privacy of our bedrooms.
It has created unprecedented opportunities
for learning, entertaining and earning a living.
But, just like anything, YouTube can be abused.
For one thing it can be mind numbingly addictive.
You sit down to watch a 3 minute clip and
three hours later you’re still slouched
in front of the computer watching cats playing
the piano, or hopefully, you know, watching
a Biographics video!